[Applause]
foreign
anyway so we have this issue with the
UAW and it's getting pretty interesting
and one Democrat one Republican uh
nominee for president is decided to take
it on and that would be Senator Tim
Scott from the great state of South
Carolina let's give a warm Hannity
audience welcome to Senator Scott
how are you great to see you doing okay
you know I'm Hannity all right oh we
love having you great to see you again
as well absolutely uh we had a great
time in South Carolina with you thank
you for coming down we always love to
see you in South Carolina I love South
Carolina better than here you bring them
we all love South Carolina better than
New York
absolutely all right good to be home I
don't think I often disagree with you
we've been friends a long time that's
true and I heard your comments about
Reagan and the UAW and you you strike
you get fired yes here's where what
might differ from you a little bit and
tell me where I might be wrong I'm
looking at the UAW and they by the way
their four day work week 32 hours take
that proposal no way that's not okay I
work like 90 hours a week sorry I don't
nobody gets a four day work week okay
yes I don't know anybody that doesn't
work you know 16 hours 14 hours a day
but here's the thing they're getting
they are totally losing their jobs
because of Joe Biden yes and this push
towards elected Vehicles absolutely 4.5
billion dollar profit loss on the EV
line of Ford this year that they are
killing these workers that should be
what what recourse do they have without
any question anytime you have a
president who drives us to inflationary
levels of 16 this is like the sequel to
the Jimmy Carter years it is devastating
and it's devastating working class
Americans they've lost thousands of
dollars of spending power and without
any question whether you're a non-union
or a union worker you're being
devastated by the Biden nomics
devastated one of the things I focused
on Sean that's really important is the
fact that in the first y'all remember
that 1.9 trillion dollar covid package
deal passed in 2021 there was 86 billion
dollars to bail out the Unions that's so
it's terrible they keep offering unions
are forcing the Democrats you know
they're using they own them they own
them they own them and when that happens
the taxpayers there's no such thing as a
federal dollar they're your dollars
they're all your dollars
putting
86 billion dollars of your money into
Shoring up Union pensions because they
keep over promising and under delivery
it's just wrong we need a president who
says we are not going to subsidize
unions period you make the deal you live
by the deal if it goes daily up it's not
on the back of the taxpayer how do you
like this idea I mean usually CEOs and
there's been a lot of talk about
disparity CEO pay okay but most of their
pay most time not all times is based on
performance yes what if they had the
same type of performance where everybody
has skin in the game yes everybody the
company does well these guys get massive
pay increases bonuses as well as the
CEOs would that that would keep it that
would have everyone pulling in the same
direction it would make the world a
better place here's one of the things
that happens there's a company called
Nucor Steel in South Carolina where many
of the workers there make six-figure
incomes because they get production
bonuses we should encourage and incent
compensation to match the production of
a company when you make the company more
money you should share in the profits of
that company that's all common sense in
America all right
[Applause]
all right unfortunately and lately
you've distinguished yourself with some
of your fellow candidates and and
um and I read it with with great
interest because I think that the issue
politically of abortion not the moral
side of this although I can they're
probably intertwined but the political
side of it is I think probably the
country politically is at the Dobbs
decision 15 weeks 12 weeks and you said
there should be a ban after 15 weeks at
the states that have will now make the
decision shouldn't be able to go longer
than that absolutely well number one if
you think about the fact that at 15
weeks that baby can suck his or her
thumb
feel pain
three out of four Americans say 15 weeks
is the exact right place to be as it
relates to stopping radical States like
New York California and Illinois on
having abortion on demand up until the
day of birth
that's just wrong so exactly we as a
nation we're better than that we have to
learn to stand up for our rights and
make sure every single child in every
single state has the same rights and
that means 15 weeks to be a national
limit and I want my entire presidential
all the presidential candidates whether
it's Ron Mickey the former president
they should all join me in support of
15-week limits we can't trust California
with anything think about this think
about the shot in California
today they will take away a parent's
rights to their kids if they don't agree
with the gender decisions that's wrong
we should stand up against that
Senator Tim Scott great to see myself
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else